- Hello, I'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
- And this is the slowest
Slow Mo Guys video
we've ever done.
- Pretty interestin'.
We're gonna spin a CD
literally at warp speed
so it's gonna go so fast around and around
it's gonna start warping.
- Warp one.
- Warp one,
and then it's gonna break and shatter
into lots of different pieces.
- The critical spin rate
of a CD is 23,000 RPM.
Hopefully we'll be able to
achieve that and film it
at 28,500 frames a second.
- Okay, we've hooked up
the motor from a Hoover
or a Dyson or whatever you call it,
a vacuum cleaner, that's what it is.
- [Gavin] Got there in the end.
- In American, vacuum cleaner in American.
So it's the motor and
it spins really fast.
We've hooked it up to the mains
and hopefully it's a Dyson
so it does about sort of
like 80,000 RPM, this one,
so we'll be able to
shatter the CD with this.
- [Gavin] How small do you
think the CD pieces will be?
- I reckon they'll be dust.
- [Gavin] Dust?
- Dust, yeah.
- [Gavin] Dust.
- Dust.
Just a little bit of dust.
Yeah, we've hooked it up.
Got two washers here to secure the CD
and then bolted it in.
Just gonna spin it round.
- So I'm excited because we're
using a new Phantom today.
This is the V2511 and
it's the fastest camera
we've ever used at 720p it'll
do 28,500 frames a second
and at its lowest resolution
will do a million frames a second.
- So we've hooked up this
variac to the Dyson motor
so that we can vary the speed
and the power going into the motor
and then dial it up until
it breaks and shatters
and see what RPM we get to.
- [Gavin] Okay, Dan I'm slightly scared.
- I'm scared too.
I don't know what's gonna happen.
Lemme see my record time there.
Okay what have we got?
- 2.6 seconds.
- Okay, I'll let you know
when it's about to go
and I think we'll have to go.
- [Gavin] Yeah, all right,
go for it, I'll run in there.
- [Dan] Okay, hang on, I'm
just gonna turn this on.
- [Gavin] I'll be like this.
- [Dan] Hold on.
Okay, it's started up.
Got loads to go yet.
Oh man, not yet.
Two, ah!
Ah!
Whoa!
- Bloody hell.
I thought it was gonna go to the moon.
- [Dan] Yeah, it went
higher than it did before.
It went to like 100,000.
- [Gavin] Did it really.
So as you can see from
this, 2,500 frames a second
isn't nearly fast enough
to see what happened there.
Let's look at what we got.
- All right.
You can see it warpin', look at that.
- Wow!
- It's moving so much.
- Oh my god.
- Look at, look at the shape of it.
It's movin' like the whole thing.
Whoa!
- Whoa!
Oh my god.
- Ah man.
- That looked amazing!
- Literally just shattered
into tiny little bits.
- It's just physics don't know what to do
and the CD's just like nope, I'm gone.
- No, I'm out, I'm done.
- That's amazing.
- Let's see that again.
- I've seen that at lower speeds.
I've never seen it so clear.
- What frame rate was that?
- 28,500.
- 28,000 frames a second.
- So that looked good.
It looked amazing and I
never thought I would say
that 28,000 frames a
second isn't fast enough.
- [Dan] It's not enough.
- But when you can go
faster, you go faster.
We did that at 720p.
I've lowered the resolution to 768 by 480
giving us a top frame rate
of 62,000 frames a second.
- [Dan] Oh my goodness.
Well I'm not gonna work it out now
but that's a lot slower than real time.
- [Gavin] Well, if we play back at 25,
that's gonna slow a minute.
That's gonna slow a second
down to about 40 minutes.
- [Dan] This?
- [Gavin] Yeah.
- We've got more stuff
on the CD this time.
Again, for scientific
purposes we've got a face.
- All right Daniel, full speed.
- Full speed ahead, warp drive on.
Okay.
This is satisfyin' to turn.
- Is it?
- Yeah.
Oh man.
- [Gavin] You can actually
see it warping in real,
in like, in real life.
- That was awesome.
I jumped.
- [Gavin] You jumped?
- Yeah.
- It'll happen eventually.
- That's the thing when you're filming
at this many frames a second,
the actual moment where something happens
takes forever to get to.
Whoa!
- Whoa.
- That was awesome 'cause you
saw the actual shape of the CD
and the cracks in it were perfectly like
the direction the CD was spinning.
If so, it was more like a
spiral effect on the CD.
Like a turbine.
That was cool.
- All right, so that was
at 62,000 frames a second.
- 62, so what's that?
40 minutes for one?
- Yeah, so
what I've done here, I've
lowered the resolution
to 384 by 256, very small.
- 256 yeah.
- But hopefully big enough
to see some shattering.
Frame rate let's.
- What can we get?
- Take it up, 80, 100, 120.
- 150.
170,000 frames a second.
- So that's, we had basically 62 last time
and it's 170,000.
That's ridiculous.
- I'm actually gettin'
giddy just from the speeds.
- That's nuts.
- Gettin' too excited.
- Let's blow it!
That's ridiculous.
- We shot 96 gigs.
- In that, in?
- Oh look at that.
- That's awesome.
- Just the shape it
makes when it shatters.
- Like a little tree.
Wow, that's cool.
- [Gavin] That is amazing.
- [Dan] It's wicked.
- [Dan] It goes like either side
of the middle hole doesn't it?
Like, it follows the shape of the CD
and then finally meets up again
at the other side.
- So now what we're doing
is we've moved the CD rig
so the camera is looking down the edge
so we can hopefully see how much it warps
from the side angle which I
think could be interesting
and we'll film this at
28,500 frames a second again.
Dan's just doing some final touches
to the artwork of the CD.
- Side view of the warp speed.
Oh whoa!
- What is happening?
- Look at that.
Doesn't even look like a CD anymore.
That's amazing.
Look at that.
- It's so bent.
It's spinning like at
different speeds from its warp.
- That's amazing.
The warp just seems to be staying there
while the CD spins
further and further around
almost like the air is
pushing it, it looks like.
- That's ridiculous.
- It's crazy.
I think it's tryin' to take off.
That's awesome.
- You can see why it gives out.
- Yeah.
- That is some force.
I woulda thought that the warp
would've gone around with the
disc, if you know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah.
- All right, here's the
moment of impact, oi!
- See ya later.
- Oh, all the bits that
hit the vice just exploded.
- Oh man, they got pulverized.
- Yeah, solid.
Well that was some incredible footage.
I have never seen that, that slow before.
- Yeah, that's the fastest
thing we've ever filmed
and the fastest frame rate as well.
- 170,000 frames a second.
- That's nuts.
- The CD got very small.
- Yeah, I liked that it was so
powerful that we actually had
a spindle of the CDs at the
bottom of the device here
and it's cracked through
one, two, three CDs
with just a shard.
- One CD ruined
all the others.
- One shot just went crack,
straight through the level of three CDs.
- Our lovely clean, white background had
an incident of its own.
- Yeah look.
- Went straight through that.
- Look, we've pushed like a big hole
and it's just gone straight through.
Another couple there.
- I doubt the CD even noticed.
- No, no.
- Well thanks very much
for watchin' that video.
Be sure to follow us on Twitter,
buy a shirt if you want.
We sell shirts, who woulda thought
and subscribe to The Slow Mo Guys.
- Cool, sweet.